I mean we have a mental health crisis
right now in this country and that was
pre pandemic and the pandemic has by
objective measurements something like
either tripled or tent up 'old
like the mental health problems in this
country then the number of parents who
report extreme stress think when
something from like two percent to 37
percent incidents of self-harm crisis
text line use has doubled it tripled and
it's particularly bad for young people
and to me like we're really losing the
thread it's like if our people are this
anxious and depressed and sick if our
kids are struggling to this degree like
what the hell are we doing like what's
the point of anything we're doing if you
look up and you see your children
suffering yeah I mean look this is about
you know making both our physical world
and our digital world better because for
our kids the the manifestation of their
physical self and digital self will be
one in the same I would argue and I
think that that requires us to reflect
upon not only what's happening in you
know the physical part of society but
also the digital part of our society
[Music]
[Applause]